I see a greater return to
self-discipline a greater return to
foresight and a much greater willingness
to serve others to look for
opportunities out of American affluence
and the affluence they have joint I've
enjoyed to try to serve the poor and
needy elsewhere and also a recognition
that you serve the poor and needy best
if you use the old cliche teach them how
to fish rather than just giving them a
fish the great inner energy of
capitalism is to make things work into
to invent and create new things that
didn't exist before new businesses
didn't exist before and and that
requires a certain vision and a
willingness to take a chance I see lots
of goodness our new technologies and
courage that don't they I mean all the
things possibility not with
communications these days are just
amazing I see my grandchildren that is
fascinated by all the new technologies
all the different media and they seem to
live surrounded by them I can hardly
understand how to make some of them work
and they do it just like that